i'm told yeah that you know everyone
this year this was the year of so many
things
but karen's yeah karen's being out of
control and it became this whole thing
online
check out the karen losing it the
maskless karen the karen screaming at
the walmart
you coined the term karen for the white
woman being uh called karen yes
yes i don't know if there's any other
people before that you know what i mean
so you you think you you were the first
one to do it a while ago i think i was
the first one to do it a while ago for
the white women being named karen
because you know i grew up in the
suburbs so i'm i'm used to that
you know i mean it was always cairns
around me when i was growing up you knew
a lot of karen's growing up a lot of
karen's when i was growing up you know
and they always uh
they would always talk and um uh that
that's uh that's black people repellent
you know what i mean there's
them talking is black people neighbor
repellent what's the kind of thing that
karen would ask you
if you know you had moved into the
neighborhood oh she oh
so are you renting are you buying
really okay so you're in that big house
by yourself
yes i am you want to be my maid
is that why you keep asking me for
there's karen's all around me now you
know i live
i live in the burbs again you know what
i mean it took a couple i lived in the
burbs and i went to the hood and i moved
back to the burbs that's how i did it
you know what i mean i had to get the
experience i'm coaching you know what i
mean
but the karen's i know were like jills
and and barbara's and all of that they
just they're
they're carrot anything it's a carrot
it's a carrot doesn't matter
they're out there they're out there
cameron's out here